Легкий, світлий та сучасний
Саме таким бачать "Музей революції гідності" в архітектурному бюро Kleihues + Kleihues
проект якого, власне, і виграв
конкурс на будівництво меморіалу
Для німецького архітектора Яна Кляйгуза
український проект унікальний,
адже має бути одночасно і музеєм
і меморіалом загиблих під час
трагічних подій на Майдані
Поєднати це було непросто
Це дещо патетична тема
і треба було бути дуже обережним,
щоб уникнути цієї патетики в проекті
Також слід зважати на те, що
коли уважно поглянути на історію Києва
то не можна все ділити на добре і зле, чорне та біле
це нагромадження різних обставин
Уникнути пафосу хочуть
за допомогою прозорих форм
і того, яким чином структурований фасад
Німецькі архітектори розробили
досить відкриту, сучасну будівлю
яка, на їхню думку, не справляє пафосного враження
а навпаки - є привітною
Ідеться про меморіал,
який реконструює шлях революціонерів
і який має нагадувати про жертв революції
Цей шлях іде вгору повз готель Україна та Жовтневий палац та завершується на пагорбі
Там і має бути розташований музей
Ідея полягає в тому, аби продовжити цей шлях
у самому музеї та навколо нього
Кляйгуз зізнається: у 2014-му
за трагічними подіями на Майдані майже не стежив
Проте коли почав займатися проектом,
багато довідався про ті події
і був вражений
як таке могло відбуватися у сучасному світі
На Алеї слави німецького архітектора дуже вразили
меморіальні "ніші" з бруківки
що їх спорудили родичі загиблих на Майдані
Власне, цю ідею архітектори перейняли як тему для фасаду будівлі майбутнього музею
Мені здалося, що там є два види пам'ятників
З одного боку, ніші, які виглядають
ніби вони цілком індивідуально були зведені послідовниками
Каміння, складене одне на одне
Це дуже гарні округлі ніші,
в яких стоять фото та квіти
З іншого боку - пам'ятники, які, на мою думку,
були, так би мовити
сплановано там зведені
Вони менш гарні і менш вражаючі
ніж пам'ятні ніші, збудовані з каміння
"Музей революції гідності" зведуть
на Алеї героїв Небесної сотні
де загинула більшість майданівців
Проте коли це станеться, поки невідомо
термінів ані початку, ані завершення
будівельних робіт ще немає.